the Prime Minister the businessman and
the BBC chair Richard Sharp has already
admitted he made an approach to a senior
Whitehall official for the Canadian
millionaire Sam Blythe ahead of Mr
Blythe providing an 800 000 pound loan
guarantee for Boris Johnson now MPS have
questioned why he didn't declare this
given he was applying to government for
the job of BBC chair at the time
the cross party select committee
concluded Mr Sharp made significant
errors of judgment and should consider
the impact his emissions will have on
trust in him the BBC and the public
appointments process one Committee
Member today going further I don't see
how he can carry on how can he argue
with the BBC's case how can he talk
about impartiality give them that he
withhold withheld this important
information from us and given the low
levels of trust that he now enjoys
amongst BBC staff the select committee
had previously approved Mr Sharp's
appointment and at a hearing last week
the BBC chair maintained he had followed
the rules why didn't you disclose it the
um
just to be clear I didn't I didn't
arrange the loan I did at the meeting
helped with the loan the loan would not
have happened to presumably if you
hadn't played the role that you did
I as I said I was I was ensuring due
process was followed in a statement
today Richard Sharp spokesperson said Mr
Sharp appreciates that there was
information that the committee felt it
should have been made aware of in his
pre-appointment hearing he regrets this
and apologizes
as for Boris Johnson he's insisted
Richard Sharp knew nothing of his
finances despite a leaked memo
suggesting otherwise this is all more
damaging for the previous occupant here
than the current one but there's still
political danger for Rishi sunak
remember Richard Sharp used to be the
prime minister's boss when he worked in
finance and the risk is the public just
see another argument about money power
and personal connections this Minister
saying we should wait for an inquiry by
the Whitehall appointments Watchdog to
conclude this is really something which
the public appointments commissioner
must look at and we must wait wait for
his judgment but the most important
issue is that there should be full and
open transparency and I think that is is
at the heart of the questions the BBC is
conducting an internal review into its
chair but has re-emphasized that Richard
Sharp's position is entirely a matter
for the government it's an unwelcome
rally for the corporation and one with
possible problems for the Prime Minister
too